So, as we talked about in our example
before, we need to use the distributive
property here to figure out how this minus
sign affects all of the terms inside the
second set of parentheses. First off
though, since nothing is happening outside
of the parentheses, on the front end at
least, for this first part of our
expression, we're just going to rewrite
that without the parentheses. And then, we
remember the trick that we talked about
before that a minus sign actually means
plus -1 times whatever you want
to subtract. So instead of the minus sign
right here, that's what I am going to
write, we're adding -1 times
this entire thing in parentheses. And now,
we need to use the distributive property
to multiply -1 by every term in
here, this is going to affect the 4x^2 and
the -2x and also the 4. So, going one
step further, you'll notice that for right
now, I've let there be an addition sign
between all of the terms over here, and
then their sign is being determined
within the term before I change any of
these to subtraction signs if they're
going to be them eventually. So, now we
can carry out the simplification within
each term. Remember that if you have two
negative numbers multiplied together, they
equal a positive number. So, -1 times -2 is
actually equal to positive 2. And now,
since we have two terms where I'm adding a
negative, I'm going to switch these to
negative signs or minus signs. And then,
last but not least, we rearrange and
combine like terms. So our final answer is
3x^2+4x-3.
Awesome job. There are a ton of steps as
you can see in this problem, and there are
a lot of places where it's really easy to
make a silly mistake, so that's why it's
super important that we write every single
step down. I know this probably feels
really tedious, but, in the end, as you
keep practicing getting more proficient,
it's going to be the thing that gives you
the right answers. So please just keep
taking the time to write out all of your
steps and don't take any shortcuts quite
yet.